[Music]
we all have our dark for the secrets we
don't want anyone to know and so does
the musical hit Disney movie zombies but
lucky for you we've got all the secrets
right here ready to be revealed just
wait until you hear number one and you
won't believe what darling dove Cameron
said new to the things make sure to give
us a like if you love zombies as much as
us and hit the subscribe button for more
great videos now on to 10 dark secrets
in disney's zombies Zed's rainbow head
in the original 2012 zombies and
cheerleaders which our exciting and
thrilling 2018 zombies decom was based
on dead didn't have colored hair he only
had a bit of green splattered on his
forehead before Milo Manheim's shown in
the title role of Zed Luke vineyard Brad
said to life so from 2012 to 2018 the
vision of the characters changed
drastically somewhere along the way no
longer did Disney want the zombies to
simply fit in at zebra they wanted them
to be noticeable to stand out this
required a long look at the styles and
contradictions between the zombies and
the cheerleaders we're certain there
must have been some major disagreements
on the topic however before settling on
the green locks as a zombies Rock in
this film they went through some other
options first dad was actually going to
sport rainbow hair not a full rainbow
but a mini one Milo's head quickly
became a hair dyeing scientific
experiment to find the true Zedd Milo
said to Seventeen magazine that before
the hair teen is settled on the dark
green it went through many changes going
from a bright neon similar to Jared
Leto's Joker in Suicide Squad as well as
teal green and yellow tips we see why
they wanted to keep the rainbow head a
secret secretly the nicest cast member
of course the Disney cast of zombies are
talented funny and kind but what about
the dude who plays the antagonist Trevor
Tordjman brings the evil bully to leader
of Bucky to life so believably it's easy
to think he must actually be mean well
surprise surprise a little secret kept
under wraps to protect those Auggie's
characters trevor is in fact one of the
nicest and funniest cast members how do
we know this well
meg Donnelly among almost every other
actor on the film has
hosted about him or made a comments
referring to his humor and generosity
meg spoke about Trevor saying he would
always make her break character on set
making her laugh the cast agrees that
despite his main character it has
nothing to do with who he is as a person
the clearly talented actor also played
by the lead of James on the next step
showing off his crazy dancing skills if
being an incredible actor a good person
and a crazy good dancer isn't enough
he's funny to boot Trevor you supposed
to zone hilarious vine videos' from 2013
to 2015 talk about the secret funny guy
we all want to know more about the
massive trampoline BAM is the song from
the musical that has been praised the
most that upbeat catchy zombie tune when
Addison breaks some rules and goes to
meet said at the zombie party it's quite
the scene but it wasn't always the
musical number it ended up to be in the
film hello giggles interviewed Chris
Scott the choreographer of the film as
well as McDonald E and Milo Manheim to
ask them about this number and how it
all came together Chris said it was the
trickiest number in the film but the end
result paid off the director wanted to
make it clear through this dance
sequence but the zombies were superhuman
one day when Chris Scott brought in sort
of the trampoline Milo did a backflip on
it and Chris loved it Milo told Chris he
does this sort of stuff all the time the
next day there was a massive 30-foot
trampoline called an air track covering
the whole floor this allowed everyone to
jump higher and perform cool moves in
the air while being able to land on a
safe ground meg then suggested to have
her mouth be filmed double time while
singing so they could slow it down to
slow mo in post-production are we making
sense that way if they slow down to slow
mo then the song would still be in time
but a collaboration leaving us all
wondering how the shizzle sticks did
they do that
sneaking out we all did that at some
point sneaking out didn't we whether you
did or didn't we all know that rush of
adrenaline exploring a new place for the
first time
zombies shot in Toronto Canada which
required the main cast to be flown in
from Los Angeles and put up at a hotel
for the duration of the shoot so what
does the cast of young actors and
dancers do in between their days of work
well get out and about
sweat the cast bonded anytime they
weren't shooting by gathering in actress
Kylie Russell's hotel room they would
all go pick up Starbucks first then jam
to music have dance parties and just
chill together however when they wanted
to leave the hotel room behind the
newbies to the Toronto City would go and
see the great North Toronto was their
playground when the cast wasn't on set
performing or jamming together in a
hotel room becoming what we can clearly
see are the best of friends they go out
to see the city in Meg Donnelly's
Instagram posts she often had the
notable see in Tower or skyline of
Toronto sleeping behind her she even
captions when photo that Toronto will
always be home for her we wonder if they
were ever recognized were they allowed
to go without security bonzo is really
saying something ever speak gibberish
just for fun now don't judge but we do
however Bronte doesn't do it for fun
this zombie only knows how to speak
zombie language Bonzo is the lovable
energetic zombie that is always spewing
out sentences we don't understand
however actor James Godfrey who brings
bronzer to life says he knew exactly
what his character is saying each time
he spoke Mylo even reported that
whenever rewatched the takes banda would
repeat his gibberish sentences on points
how impressive did he make up a whole
language just for Bonzo James must have
done a lot of work making each word in
zombie language means something in
English in Seventeen magazine
they even title an entry Bonzo nailed
his complicated zombified lines every
time it definitely takes work to make
audiences still love you even when they
can't understand you and James did just
that
Miley went on to say that James would
have full conversations with him in the
film and he'd have no idea what Bonzo
said but James did though we have
absolutely no clue what Bonzo was saying
we sure did fall in love with him
original director replace this may be
the darkest most shockingly kept secrets
around in the zombies Disney film in
2017 deadline announced the director of
zombies as Jeffrey Hornaday the
brilliant vision behind teen beach movie
and teen Beach - Jeffrey is also a
successful choreographer since he began
in nineteen
- not only did she direct the teen beach
films he choreographed them so when it
was announced that Hornaday would be
directing zombies many wondered if he
was also choreographing the musical
numbers in addition sweetie high
reported that porn a day would be
directing however all the sudden the
director chat was shut down and emerged
a new director Paul Pollan who has
directed many busy shows and D cons was
the newly hired director of zombies Paul
also has to award winds from the
Directors Guild of America so what
happened to Hornaday he didn't even end
up choreographing any musical numbers
clearly there isn't an issue between
Hornaday and Disney as he's slated to
direct the new installment of the High
School Musical movies whatever happens
behind closed doors we'll never know but
their secret is out sorry Jeff Paul's
taking over and he did a more than
stellar job what do you think would be
different if the director of teen beach
movie had also done zombies - let us
know in the comments below a wig of real
hair it's always been about the hair
especially on the set of zombies yes we
are once again back to crazy and
meticulous secrets of the main
characters hair styles and colors we
previously mentioned that Zed's final
hair color decision was the dark dream
that we can all recognize now as zombies
hair but did you know that milo Manheim
actually went the extra mile for the
movie Milo dyed his hair green for the
role of Zed he was the only actor in the
film who actually dyed their hair
everyone else had their hair done each
morning talk about a green shower at
night washing that out as for Meg
Donnelly's role of Addison the hair
stylists really went back and forth on
the color in the film we learned that
Allison's real hair is white but that
she attempts to hide it under a wig so
Meg tried a lot of brown and red wigs
but ultimately the production decided to
go with Mike's natural blonde hair color
however since Addison was wearing a wig
meg still had to wear a wig so it looks
proper while filming oh the secrets hair
stylists must know all the hours with
stars in their chairs relentless
auditions any time a major film is being
made one of the most important decisions
is the casting the actors bring the
story to life and make the audience want
to keep watching more in
the casting process was long but we sure
think it paid off with the perfect cast
of characters zombies was a huge success
and we sure hope there will be a sequel
don't you
none of the actress from the 2012
zombies into leaders film which zombies
was based on may Deven we're certain
casting saw all major young characters
in Hollywood for the leading roles so
how did they possibly find unknown Milo
Manheim the star reports that casting
director
amber Horne saw Milo in a performance of
rent and approached him saying that he's
tried to shoot they're zombies
Milo grew up doing theater musicals so
zombies was perfect for him his mother
Camryn Manheim is a Broadway actress
making him feel more comfortable in his
breakout role
Milo auditions for months and was seen
multiple times by around the sixth
audition he was paired up with different
Addison's for chemistry Reed's when Milo
and mag Donnelly met they instantly
connected Landing them both the leads in
the epic zombies Disney film post
filming relationship in bloom we've all
heard the famous stories of actors
fallen in love while filming the most
common being Angelina Jolie and Brad
Pitt Zac Efron and Vanessa Hudgens from
High School Musical or The OC couple
Adam Brody and Rachel Bilson how about
Tom Cruise in Nicole Kidman who we could
go on
but you get it but the cast of zombies
it sure appears like a romance is in
bloom between the two leads who share
crazy on-screen chemistry meg and Milo
however this connection we all witnessed
watching the films could be just great
acting but we're starting to notice it
off screen - both Megan Milo posts
Instagram photos together being
extremely close they tout themselves as
best friends but do you think there may
be a glimmer more this is just
speculation but we're wondering if
Disney is trying to keep an off-screen
romance a secret after all rehearsing
and filming for three months together
you would definitely get to know someone
very well in addition it is well known
that from the moment Megan Milo mad at
the audition chemistry reads there was a
spark it was clear that this would be
acting duo they needed to bring the film
to life which is exactly what they did
with their electric energy both the lead
actors speak about each other with such
love
boasting about each other's talents sure
seems like there may be something more
than friendship do you think there's
something more there leave us a comment
below with
I dove Cameron throw shade this is one
online scuffle we're sure Disney is
desperately trying to hide our last
secret revealed involving darling dove
Cameron yep you heard that right this
sweetheart Disney star threw some
hardcore shade over at the zombies foam
dug the star of The Descendants through
a Twitter punch at zombies dubbed tweet
in response to a descendants to account
tweet which said the synopsis of zombies
have been seen it sounded very similar
to descendants alluding that zombies
copied the descendants storyline dogs
like this to be from the descendants to
account and retweeted it with a comment
crazy crazy baby baby
that's some serious shade that the
leading lady is not hiding from the
public sure a deaf Cameron may have some
beef with zombies as another decom
competition but can they all just get
along we sure hope that the cast of
zombies gets a shot at the sequel
because the first one was so darn
entertaining
maybe Dov has just threatened that
zombies will soon be taking over the
Disney popularity green envy is never
pretty dove except on those zombies
heads what did you think was the most
shocking secret that we revealed leave
us a comment below thanks for watching
10 dark secrets and Disney zombies see
you next time
[Music]